♪
>> THE FIGHT OVER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S DOCUMENTS IS HEATING UP.
LATE LAST NIGHT, THE DOJ FILED
AN OPPOSING RESPONSE TO TRUMP'S
REQUEST FOR A SPECIAL MASTER TO
REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS SEIZED
DURING A MAR-A-LAGO RAID.
PROSECUTORS SAID TRUMP LACKED
STANDING AND THAT THE DOCUMENTS,
QUOTE:  BELONG TO THE UNITED
STATES, NOT HIM.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT FAIRNESS.
HOW CAN ANYONE TRUST THE DOJ TO
STOP THEMSELVES FROM GOING
FISHING THROUGH TRUMP'S FILES
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN PROVEN TIME
AND TIME AGAIN TO BE SO BIASED
AGAINST HIM ALL TRUMP IS ASKING
FOR INDEPENDENT ARBITER TO COME
IN AND SIFT THROUGH WHAT THE FBI
TOOK FROM HIM.
ARE THEY COVERED BY EXECUTIVE OR
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE?
SOMEONE NEEDS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS DO YOU TRUST THE
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY BURIED
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP TO FAIRLY
MAKE THOSE CALLS.
NOW THE TRUMP TEAM HAS UNTIL
TONIGHT TO COUNTER THE DOJ'S
FILING BEFORE JUDGE EILEEN
CANNON RULES TOMORROW.
MEANWHILE, THE DOJ JUST UNVEILED
CAT NIP FOR THE LIBERAL MEDIA.
A PHOTO OF HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS SCATTERED ALL OVER THE
FLOOR OF MAR-A-LAGO.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IS CALLING
IT A STRIKING VISUAL AID.
OH HOW STRIKING.
DEMOCRATS RUSHED TO SAY CAN YOU
BELIEVE THIS IS HOW TRUMP STORED
STOLEN TOP SECRET MATERIAL?
AND RHINO LIZ CHENEY SAYS SHE
HAS SEEN ENOUGH.
SHE IS SAYING YET MORE
INDEFENSIBLE CONDUCT BY DONALD
TRUMP REVEALED THIS MORNING,
CASE CLOSED.
THE MEDIA SURE CAN'T BELIEVE IT
EITHER.
THEY ARE BLOWN AWAY.
WATCH.
>> A STUNNING NEW PHOTO RELEASED
OVERNIGHT, FOLDERS LABELED TOP
SECRET, SECRET, SENSITIVE.
>> IT'S ONE THING TO READ IN A
COURT FILING THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAD CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AT HIS HOME, IT'S
QUITE ANOTHER TO SEE IT FOR
OURSELVES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS.
>> STAGGERING NEW REVELATIONS,
EVIDENCE THAT HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WERE LIKELY MOVED AND
HIDDEN.
>> AND THANK GOODNESS FOR
JOURNALISTS LIKE MAGGIE HABERMAN
WHO ALSO NOTED THAT TRUMP HAD A
COPY OF "TIME" MAGAZINE IN
THERE, TOO.
IT ALL GAVE THE DOJ EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WANTED.
HAVE TRUMP LOOK LIKE A SLOPPY
CRIMINAL WHO WAS JUST
MISHANDLING TOP SECRET
DOCUMENTS.
AND MADE THE DOJ LOOK LIKE THE
GOOD GUYS FOR RAIDING
MAR-A-LAGO.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTED TO
ALL OF THIS BY SAYING TERRIBLE
THE WAY THE FBI DURING THE RAID
OF MAR-A-LAGO THREW DOCUMENTS
HAPHAZARDLY ALL OVER THE FLOOR,
PRANCE PRETENDING IT WAS ME THAT
DID IT AND THEN STARTED TAKING
PICTURES OF THEM FOR THE PUBLIC
TO SEE.
THOUGHT THEY WANTED TO KEEP THEM
SECRET.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT'S HOW
THE FBI FOUND THOSE DOCUMENTS?
I BET DON LEMON THINKS THAT'S
ALL HAD ALL HAPPENED.
>> EVERYONE DESERVES A DEFENSE
AND ALL OF THAT.
I GET THAT, INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY.
>> OF COURSE.
>> BUT, THE FACT IS, WE ARE
ARGUING OVER WHETHER HE IS
GUILTY OR NOT.
OF COURSE HE IS.
HE TOOK THE DOCUMENTS.
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT JUST
HOW BAD THE DOCUMENTS ARE.
HOW TOP TOP SECRET THEY ARE.
NOT THAT HE DID SOMETHING WRONG.
>> Judge Jeanine: IF YOU ARE NOT
CONVINCED THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
WITCH-HUNT, WELL, NEW REPORTS
SAY THE DOJ IS WAITING PAST THE
MIDTERMS TO REVEAL ANY TRUMP
CHARGES.
THIS IS A BLATANTLY POLITICAL
MOVE.
THE DOJ HAS A POLICY OF NOT
BRINGING CHARGES AGAINST
POLITICAL FIGURES SO CLOSE TO AN
ELECTION.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO CHARGE
TRUMP IN ORDER TO AFFECT THE
ELECTION.
THE SIMPLE ACT OF RAIDING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S HOME CAST AS
MAJOR SHADOW OVER THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY LESS THAN THREE MONTHS
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON JOE
BIDEN'S CRIME INFESTED CITIES,
EMPTY GROCERY SHELVES, HIGH GAS
PRICES AND INFLATION, EVERYONE
IS TALKING ABOUT TRUMP.
THE BORDER, INFLATION, HIGH GAS,
WHO CARES?
TRUMP HAS A LOVE FOX NEWS ALERT
ROCKET MAN AT MAULLER.
I REMEMBER THE DAYS WHEN
DEMOCRATS CRIED FOUL WHEN COMEY
OPENED UP AN INVESTIGATION RIGHT
BEFORE AN ELECTION.
UNFORTUNATELY BIG MISTAKE SUCH
AN APPALLING ACT THAT GOES
AGAINST THE TRADITION OF
PROSECUTORS.
>> HE MADE A MISTAKE ON THIS HE
COULDN'T TAKE THE HEAT FROM A
REPUBLICAN.
MAYBE HE IS NOT IN THE RIGHT
JOB.
>> NEW BUT NOW THAT THE SHOE IS
ON DONALD TRUMP'S FOOT, I DON'T
HEAR ANY OF TH